WE CAN'T WAIT TO READ IT.
THANKS SO MUCH.
>> THANKS SO MUCH.
>> Laura: HAVE DEMOCRATS
WASTED THE LAST TWO YEARS
GOVERNING OVER FRUITLESS
OBSESSIONS WITH THE MUELLER
REPORT WINDING DOWN, THE
GOVERNMENT STEPPING BACK FROM
THEIR CAUSE TO IMPEACH TRUMP.
WAS THE DEMOCRATIC OBSESSION
OVER TRUMP AND RUSSIA IT REALLY
WORTH IT FOR THE PARTY QUEST MAY
HERE WITH ANSWER, GLENN
GREENWALD, FOUNDER OF THE
INTERCEPTS.
GLENN GREENWALD DELMA, GREAT TO
SEE YOU.
YOU'LL NOTICE THAT HARDLY ANY OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTS OF
CANDIDATES, AND THE LIST IS
GROWING SEEMINGLY BY THE DAY,
THEY EVEN MENTION TRUMP AND
RUSSIA.
IT IS REALITY FINALLY SINKING IN
FOR THE DEMOCRATS?
SOME OF THESE NEW POLES ABOUT
MUELLER WHAT THEY ARE THINKING
ABOUT.
>> YEAH, WE ACTUALLY SAW THIS,
LAURA, DURING THE 2018 MIDTERM
WHERE THE VICTORIOUS DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES, KNOWING THE LOCAL
DISTRICTS REALLY WELL, ALMOST
NEVER MENTIONED THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL COMMITTEE AND MSNBC,
EXCUSE THE REDUNDANCY, HAVE
SPENT THE LAST 2.5 YEARS
OBSESSING ON TV AND ESPECIALLY
EVERYTHING ELSE, NOT THE CLAIM
THAT TRUMP COLLUDED WITH RUSSIA,
BUT THAT RUSSIA ACTUALLY
CONTROLLED DONALD TRUMP IN SOME
SORT OF, YOU KNOW, TOM CLANCY
TYPE OF ESPIONAGE WAY.
AS A RESULT OF BLACKMAIL OR
OTHER KINDS OF LEVERAGE.
THAT DISAPPEARED FROM THE
WINNING CAMPAIGNS OF 2018
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT PEOPLE
DON'T WAKE UP IN THE MORNING
WORRIED ABOUT PUTIN AND THE 2020
COUNTED ITS ARE SEEING THE
WHEELS ARE FALLING OFF THE CART
OF THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION AND
BARELY MENTIONED IN RECOGNITION
OF THAT FACT.
>> Laura: GLENN, PELOSI I
NOSED OUT OUT THERE TODAY IN
MISSOURI, SHE WAS BACKTRACKING A
MISSOURI, SHE WAS BACKTRACKING L
MISSOURI, SHE WAS BACKTRACKING T
MISSOURI, SHE WAS BACKTRACKING E
MISSOURI, SHE WAS BACKTRACKING B
MISSOURI, SHE WAS BACKTRACKING T
MISSOURI, SHE WAS BACKTRACKING O
MISSOURI, SHE WAS BACKTRACKING N
THAT BEING BOMBSHELL ADMISSION L
THAT BEING BOMBSHELL ADMISSION S
THAT BEING BOMBSHELL ADMISSION T
WEEK ON PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
IMPEACHMENT.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I SAID, HE'S NOT WORTH IT.
IT GOT YOUR ATTENTION.
I'VE BEEN SAYING THIS FOR TWO
YEARS, HE SHOULDN'T BE
IMPEACHED.
WHEN I SAY HE'S NOT WORTH IT,
THEN IT GOT THE PRESS.
WHAT HE'S NOT WORTH IS THE
FINANCIAL STABILITY OF AMERICA'S
WORKING FAMILIES AND THAT'S WHAT
WE ARE TRYING TO CORRECT.
WHEN THE TIME COMES, WE'LL SEE.
>> Laura: DO YOU BELIEVE HER,
WHEN THE TIME COMES, WE'LL SEE?
>> JUST PLEASE THINK ABOUT HOW
STUPID THAT IS, WHAT YOU JUST
SAID.
THE OVERRIDING THEME OF THE
DEMOCRATS FOR A TWO AND A HALF
YEARS, GOING BACK TO THE 2016
ELECTION, AS I SAID EARLIER,
DONALD TRUMP IS BLACKMAILED BY
OR CONTROLLED BY THE KREMLIN AND
FORCED TO DO THINGS AGAINST THE
INTEREST OF HIS OWN COUNTRY OF
THE UNITED STATES AND IN FAVOR
OF THIS FOR AN ADVERSARY.
IF THAT WERE TRUE AT ALL, IF
ROBERT MUELLER HAD ANY EVIDENCE
OF THAT AND HASN'T SHOWN IT TO
US, HE WOULD ALMOST BE GUILTY OF
TREASON.
IF NANCY PELOSI REALLY BELIEVE
THAT DONALD TRUMP IS SERVING THE
INTEREST OF RUSSIA AND DECIDES,
OH, WE ARE GOING TO TAKE OUR
TIME IN REMOVING HIM FROM
CONTROL OVER THE NUCLEAR ARSENAL
AND THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND THE
MILITARY, UNTIL WE FEEL LIKE WE
ARE READY TO DO IT?
YOU WOULD WONDER, DOES PUTIN
HAVE SOMETHING ON PELOSI TOO
DELMA
IF YOU REALLY HAVE THAT EVIDENCE
FOR IT?
THEY HAVE NONE AND THEY DON'T
HAVE THE INTEGRITY TO ADMIT
THAT.
>> Laura: GLENN, JUST TWO
MONTHS AGO SHE IS ON TWITTER AND
SHE'S TWEETING, WHAT DOES PUTIN
HAVE ON TRAUMA?
THE WHOLE PRESS CORPS AND
UNITED STATES FORGETS SHE SAID
THAT.
JUST TWO MONTHS AGO!
>> EXACTLY.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
I KNOW YOU KNOW THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING AND EXPOSE ABOUT SOME
REALLY INCREDIBLE CRIMINAL ACTS
ON THE PART OF THE BOLASARIO.
HE'S GOING TO BE ON
SHANNON BREAM'S SHOWN EXPERT
YOU'LL SEE WHAT A REAL SCANDAL
LOOKS LIKE.
ONLY IN OFFICE FOR TWO MONTHS,
CONCRETE TANGIBLE EVIDENCE THAT
HAS BEEN PUBLIC WE DISCLOSED
LINKING HIM TO THE WORLD'S WORST
PARAMILITARY GANGS AND
EXTRAJUDICIAL MURDERERS IN THE
COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHAT A REAL SCANDAL LOOKS
LIKE.
INSTEAD IN THE U.S., WE HAVE TWO
YEARS OF SPECULATION, CONSPIRACY
THEORIZING, ALL KINDS OF
ESPIONAGE FANTASIES THAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW REALIZING IS
NEVER GOING TO COME TO FRUITION.
MUELLER HAS NOT INDICTED ONE
AMERICAN FOR THE CRIME OF
COLLABORATION WITH THE RUSSIANS,
PEOPLE DO NOT THINK HE'S GOING
TO.
>> Laura: GLENN, ALMOST OUT OF
TIME.
THERE MAY HAVE BEEN PLACES AND
AREAS WHERE WE COULD'VE WORKED
WITH RUSSIA, EVEN WITH OUR
DISAGREEMENTS ABOUT CRIMEA, BUT
THERE MAY HAVE BEEN THINGS WE
COULD'VE WORKED ON.
WITH RUSSIA.
THAT WE COULDN'T DO.
BECAUSE OF MUELLER HANGING OVER
TRUMP.
I MEAN, JUST MAY BE.
>> THAT'S THE KEY POINT.
THE BULLET OF THE SCIENTISTS SAY
THAT THE THREAT IS THE
POSSIBILITY OF NEW THROUGH WAR
NUCLEAR WAR.
TRUMP WANTED TO ALSO.